a lot of SquarePants what is up with
that toilet that looks like two layers
of rugged bamboo they have to sit on I
wonder Squidward never wears pants his
ass is probably so cut up and wrong
after a round with that toilet but it
would be like putting clothes over
third-degree burns this is the weekend
SpongeBob and Patrick go cap Squidward
is one of those people who breaks out
the art kit when planning their calendar
I mean look at this drawing you normally
drew everything really well he went back
with yellow and pink markers to color
them in people who do this make all of
us look bad so considering spongebob has
zero going on in their shoulder
department what is even the point of
carrying a backpack you might as well
just be carrying a bag since he can't
let go of the straps also are there
wooded areas in the ocean how did they
grow trees I mean I guess there was
plenty of water so plant some seeds Oh
this show for making me rationalize this
and to haul days with now damn dude if
you've got books and hot tea and all
that down here surely you have earplugs
and headphones and all sorts of stuff
that can keep you from hearing spongebob
on the regular also I don't know if I've
said this before but I will say it again
Squidward sucks he's a terrible
character and I want him to die a
horrible horrible death it's not camping
if you're ten feet from your house
doesn't matter where you are as long as
you're outdoors but it does camping a
ball staying outdoors away from your
humble abode so really on SpongeBob and
Patrick are doing is back yarding the
camping sucks in general so let's just
in that there's no way I'm gonna sit out
here all night with you total losers you
will I like how in TV shows everyone
just has camping gear ready to go which
is some Bulleit if you even have the
gear you need it's an all packed up nice
and ready at all times and there was
always a stop that has to be made for
groceries Vaseline condoms how do you
get inside that's what the Vaseline is
for this works
one good compared to just not sure
because you're at the bottom of the
ocean and so there are no stars along
under I really don't want to know where
the marshmallows work to a second to go
do I know I don't
me do you know how hard it is to spit
while saying the word bum SpongeBob and
Patrick are dicks two instruments and
music in general also where did all
these instruments come from then why
would they even bring them for and the
hell were they in that tent we saw the
tent and there was no drum set or guitar
to be seen this is relaxing not to keep
jumping on this musical instrument dream
but Squidward talked to bring a clarinet
and not a can opener fan even though he
knew he was going to want to cook his
Swedish barnacle balls at some point
baby bears and fairytales are real
see Squidward you have to really suspend
all practical parts of your mind to
exist in the world of the sponge fire
existing underwater for example it's the
stupidest thing but here it is once I
met this guy who knew this guy who knew
this guy no one will be seated as
spongebob uses his last remaining
functioning brain cell to formulate a
simple thought send him send staff
meeting icebreaker somehow makes it into
the show oh you mean character doesn't
believe other characters and finds out
they were telling the truth all along
cliche or you could just go back into
your house which should be literally
right there thanks for that tip what's
up with Squidward's arm does he already
have a cast on it does the sea bear
attack name and then bandage its victims
is it a see nurse bear
this goes on for some time
also Squidward survives this six times
you guys know you look better than you
did after the second attack good thing
we're all wearing our anti-sea why no
sir it's undergarments right Squidward
spongebob no Squidward isn't wearing
them so really spongebob is a huge dick
for even bringing that up one time a
bank you I stuck a flute in my pock
make sure you click that bell icon but
clicking the little bell icon is how you
make sure you get notified every time we
release a video so click it
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh we have clearance
Clarence Roger Roger
what's our Victor Victor Swedish
barnacle United States Canada Mexico
Panama Haiti Jamaica